[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire on va parler d'art
aujourd'hui et surtout de l'art
d'aujourd'hui je reçois en effet le
photographe nicolas guilbert pour voir
et regarder l'art un livre de photos
formidable qui en dit très long sur la
façon dont l'art est en train de nous
absorber l écrivain cécile guilbert qui
est sa femme et qui en a écrit la
préface et philosophe yves michaud
l'auteur de l'art à l'état gazeux qui
était paru en 2003 qui publie
aujourd'hui l'art c'est fini un essai
sur l'hyper esthétique et les
atmosphères qui explique un peu ce que
nous montre les photos de nicolas
guilbert et oui il était hors is sans
les avoir vu d'où l'intérêt de cette
rencontre mais parlons d'abord de notre
époque voici les images que vous avez
choisi pour la symboliser la vôtre imite
chaussée celles ci on dirait presque
d'abord c'est une oeuvre d'art oui c'est
un rond point 2 c'est une oeuvre d'art
qui a dû être payée 1 on part très cher
mais enfin voilà souvent les ronds
points c'est très ensuite vaches des
choisi parce que aujourd'hui d'autres
époques c'est on sait pas trop où on va
je veux dire que ce soit n'a plats
halal mathen et cetera on sait pas trop
mauvais parce qu'il faut bien voir que
chaque pancartes un gag a dit des villes
exactement on sait pas trop où on va
ensuite bas un rond point quand on sait
pas où on va on en refait le tour et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on est très
largement dans la répétition beaucoup de
choses y compris la politique qui tourne
énormément ensuite je veux dire c'est la
désolation 2d de la vie provinciale et
des villages français un bien il ya plus
que les ronds points et plus rien d'en
bas c'est les trottoirs de plus en plus
répressive de plus en plus rétrécies et
puis je veux dire c'est un petit clin
d'oeil aussi au gilet jaune parce que
c'est là que on commence ils ont
redécouvert la sociabilité alors quand
on re découvre la sociabilité sous la
forme d'un rond-point comme ça bah
tout est dit
[Rires]
alors votre photo vous voulez gilbert
c'est celle ci j'ai cru reconnaître la
bouche de la vérité à la bouche de la
vérité est à venir moi j'ai pris une
photo de nicolas guilbert donc c'est
plutôt une photo symbolique
contemporaine comme on le voit puisque
c'est une fameuse sculpture qui se
trouve dans le jardin de parts que des
monstres un beau marzo en italie qui est
un jardin de la renaissance construit
par un compte de tiers qui s'appelait
orsini et qui a parsemé son jardin de
sculptures symbolique et ça c'est là
alors dit portes de l'ogre ou porte des
enfers est en fait bon voilà elle
symbolise aussi une sorte d froid qui
nous saisit dans le monde contemporain
devant toutes sortes de voilà deux
phénomènes qui ont artificiellement
contrôlable on le voit pas sur la photo
mais il ya une phrase qui dit que toute
vérité s'envole j'ai pensé s'envole
voilà toute pensée de son vol mais c'est
en même temps on dit que c'est ça montre
bien l'époque d'aujourd'hui mais je suis
sûr que les gens qui vivaient en 1960 le
retrouver aussi parfaite sur 70 aussi
chaque époque et ses effrois auquel ses
choix il croit que tel calcul humide
voilà
eh bien il n'y avait pas de rond points
c'est vrai et bien commençons
[Musique]
nicolas guilbert vous êtes l'auteur des
photos figurant dans ce livre
extraordinaire que vous avez sur les
genoux voir et regarder l'art c'est
préfacé par votre femme cécile guilbert
avec des textes de philippe comar et
édité par r chairs ces photos on va les
voir défiler derrière moi elle nous
montre la confrontation des individus
d'aujourd'hui avec des oeuvres d'art à
quel moment est-ce que vous appuyez vous
sur le déclencheur de l'appareil photo
quand on les regarde et il ya une espèce
de force de l'évidence mais en même
temps comment vous y prenez qu'est ce
que vous cherchez et comment savez-vous
que vous l'avez trouvé
cartier bresson parlait du moment
décisif
moi j'ai pas le talent de cartier
bresson donc j'ai inventé un autre truc
qui est le désir absolu donc voilà il
suffit de désir est absolument faire des
images et on finit par les voir
apparaître là par exemple pour celle ci
elle et elle est là elle est statique à
aller là tout le temps fait ça c'est pas
une vraie photographie c'est un
enregistrement du réel voilà c'est ça la
ja palais y ait personne qui intervient
mais on voit bien ce que vous avez voulu
nous faire et l'ironie coulé il ya
quelque chose sur l'encadrement qu'on va
revoir beaucoup dans les photos à des
qit un cadre on se dit qu'il ya de l'art
derrière mais ça c'est assez récent là
c'est encore mieux oui c'est leur jeu
l'aiment beaucoup à l'aller formidable
elle est incroyable à un moment j'avais
essayé d'enlever le pantalon du monsieur
oui et en fait ça se casse la gueule
quand il ya plus le pantalon est
maintenant elle est l étrange oui et ça
c'est vraiment un art d'aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que pour nos ancêtres au
xviiie siècle qu'ils n'auraient pas
compris l'intérêt de cette photo il
aurait peut-être même pas compris la
photo en elle même mais aussi
parce que ça les intéressait pas la main
d'oeuvre et la main d'oeuvre de la
valetaille qui faisait sa veste et les
fournisseurs non là moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que ça renvoie aussi à
aux cadres bien sûr mais aussi à la
logistique aujourd'hui on n'arrête pas
de transporter d'ailleurs il ya
énormément de photos de transport le
regarde et on accroche sur des croche
mais regardez comme elle
ressemble à une montée là les deux avec
les donneurs et le romain oui
oui c'est vrai quelle robe mondiale
romain avec son caftan là j'ai eu un bol
ouais y'a incroyable avec le tableau de
bonnac et qui est pas mal c'est sabo est
un pompier c'est pas mal comme louis et
on va voir aussi beaucoup alors il ya à
la fois les gens qui travaillent ya
aussi les gens qui regardent l'art est
très souvent vous regardez les gens qui
regardent la donc en fait c'est un peu
sur le regard ou carrés dans cette danse
est donc oui oui mais il n'ya pas que ça
hein ça par exemple c'est sur un champ
un chapitre qui est sur l'empêchement
way dire que au début il y avait
beaucoup plus de photos et l'éditeur qui
est un personnage sérieux et responsable
m'a dit tu vas en enlever la moitié donc
j'en ai enlevé j'écoute toujours ce
qu'on me dit et donc là c'était un
chapitre sur les empêchements c'est à
dire que en bon on sait tous que le
camarade de francis bacon avait
l'habitude de mettre des des vitres
devancé ses ses tableaux et sa
l'exposition de bacon à beaubourg ils
l'ont mis à la sortie de l'exposition
face aux vitrines de l'extérieur de
beaubourg pour que les discussions ne
voyait absolument rien c'est la question
de savoir est ce que le reflet fait
partie de l'oeuvre ou pas c'est très
étrange parce que par exemple au louvre
que je fréquente depuis plus de 60 ans
il ya un certain nombre de tableaux
qu'on ne peut pas voir et d'ailleurs il
ya un texte dans le livre de philippe
comar absolument formidable sur les
gesticulations des genres est et sur
l'avc la selle elle est formidable alors
c'est parce que plus beau moi je trouve
ça dingue qu'on sait c'est une photo de
sebastiao salgado qui vit vue j'arrête
ont clairement à moi lui est un très
très très grand photographe mais il
photographie pas la même chose non hélas
tout à coup je trouve que là il ya une
oeuvre oui oui oui ça ces messieurs je
les ai envoyées à salgado et ils étaient
très contents
eux ce qui prouve qu'il a l'esprit
ouvert way et et cécile guilbert vous
les connaissez par coeur ces photos oui
oui
et bien sûr évidemment je ne suis pas
toujours avec nicolas au musée mais
assez souvent et ou en voyage quand nous
voyons visitant des expositions parce
qu'en fait des combats quelque part on
se ruine des musées est déjà suspect
c'est qu'on a peur de la vie mais bon
débat
il ya toujours des merveilles à
découvrir par tous mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya sept je pense pas que nicolas charle
fasse des fautes ont intentionnellement
de ses contemporains il va d'abord voir
des hommes mais c'est vrai qu'il se
passe tellement de choses dans les
musées maintenance est venue des espèces
de lieux qui sont qui ont perdu
complètement leur caractère locaux le
côté contemplatif qu'on avait au musée
de maintenance et des espèces d'air de
tous les musées c'est devenu un peu des
airs de tous donc il se passe toujours
décoder il se passe toujours quelque
chose au musée et il se passe toujours
des choses cocasses et incongrues et
surtout avec certains types de certains
types de productions mais là c'est un
peu l'art à l'état gazeux dont on va
parler avec yves michaud c'est de dire
que moi j'ai l'impression que la
présence d'oeuvres d'art contamine tout
ce qu'il ya autour ah oui mais on rentre
dans des atmosphères un fait mais ça
commence dès dès le projet touristique
je veux dire dès le projet de voyage
maintenant le prétexte qu'il faut qu'ils
soient culturels alors ça peut être de
plus ou moins haut niveau ça peut être
d'aller voir la joconde ça peut être de
manger une pizza ou ça peut être d'aller
voir la chapelle de rothko à
houston si vous voulez ya plusieurs
niveaux mais c'est vrai qu'on rentre
dans des atmosphères 1 je veux dire moi
j'ai groupe aimer toutes les photos de
nicolas guilbert parce qu'elles disent
tout quelque chose tout mais regardez
celle là voyage sur victrix sur la
situation de notre culture et la
situation de l'art aujourd'hui j'ai
vraiment d'effectivement c'est très
proche de bab réflexion regardez celle
ci elle est absolument fabuleux c'est on
veut comme on est absorbé par l'oeuvre
d'art mais en plus cela ya une
symbolique incroyable je sais plus le
titre de cette oeuvre de magritte mais
le fait que le le mec regarde à
l'intérieur d'une femme nue s'était même
épée je vais avec une très belle
position c'est là oui je vois que tu es
contamination on va voir que les gens
dieu sait si les gens sont pas d'une
élégance folle à notre époque mais je
trouve que tu hors d'elle les photos
tous les urgences sont élégants déchu
élégant au sens je la nourriture est
aujourd'hui non je parle pas du vêtement
je parle de l'attitude rares et comme
son attitude est la seule une attitude
révérencieuse je devrais dire parce que
quand on regarde les tableaux sur le
salon du 19e siècle c'était
véritablement des scènes d'émeute et là
aussi c'était du l'émotion du sentiment
médias aujourd'hui il ya une religiosité
au 19e siècle qu'ils allaient voir le
monde parce qu'on n'avait pas de photos
en couleur dans les journaux n'avaient
pas la télé on n'avait pas la radio donc
on allait voir le monde au musée et
notamment pendant le salon qu'il durait
six mois tellement il y avait de monde
et ne regardez pas la même chose au fond
d'une certaine manière là on voit ses
petits enfants ils se regardent eux
mêmes mais mais à force
ils font partie eux aussi de l'ensemble
oui mais vous voyez là par exemple par
rapport à ce que disait monsieur michaud
là on a des touristes là on a deux
petites filles bon il ya le papa qui
photographient les enfants et tous on
sait c'est rigolo la précédente je pense
que le type était pas un touriste un
vrai amateur d'art et le problème c'est
que
les les gens qui vont voir la joconde
aujourd'hui sont plus des amateurs de
pizzas que des amateurs de peinture oui
pour voir une icône comme on dit
aujourd'hui c'est de revenir en fait le
symbole de quelque chose saleh les
formidables alors là on voit bien le ya
quelque chose de totalement naturel et
aimé que duchamp avait très très bien
théorisée avec ses riddims aide vous
poser n'importe quoi dans un musée ça
devient une oeuvre d'art et si ça et si
c'est à vous dire que maurizio cattelan
c'est n'importe quoi
non non mais ce sera retenu contre vous
c'est un vrai meneur hitchcock et à la
6e' absolue je crois que c'était un type
qui travaillaient bois
travaille énormément et bougeait
beaucoup de bruit sur catane il ya
beaucoup d'humour et la preuve je me
suis laissé prendre vous connaissez
l'histoire de la femme de ménage
d'un musée qui a déblayé tout un tas de
dossiers seront tous et j'ai vu des
types s'extasier devant des extincteurs
on peut sans véritablement que c'était
des oeuvres j'apprécie le coût de la
banane est très drôle moi oui moi je
fais beaucoup mais c'est un autre fait
débat celui là est formidable là aussi
on parle de contamination mais je pense
qu'ils le font exprès je crois pas non
non il ya ou peut-être la feuillade la
fatigue et puis ya peut-être aussi les
audio guides
non mais à mon avis ce pays car ils
sont en train de se de se dire on va
faire à domicile
bien sûr oui mais y ait beaucoup de
comique de répétition dans votre dans
votre livre c'est à dire qu'on voit bien
que consciemment ou pas on a tendance à
imiter les oeuvres d'art qui sont à côté
de nous il y en a plein au louvre par
exemple il ya toute une série en
particulier au rez-de-chaussée dans la
dans la statuaire alors je sais pas
exactement je pense que c'est la
statuaire
romaine on voit des gens qui prennent
des poses les mêmes poses que le bon ça
c'est un peu du pain béni pour pour la
photographie mais il faut pas il faut
pas trop trop abusé de ce genre oui je
trouve que vous ça reste assez spontané
ça c'est en fait c'est un autoportrait
son ami jacques
c'est une longue histoire je vous
raconterai
et bon elle évidemment il faut extrême
il métisse assez incroyable ouais avec
le chassériau derrière et elles sont
très gentilles way très très gentil
mais je me demande c'est si on est les
mêmes au musée qu'ailleurs je crois
beaucoup on en reparlera tout à l'heure
mais je crois qu'on est on est on est
parfaitement
influencé par part au tour mais je me
demande et c'est ce que vous montrez
aussi si les oeuvres elles-mêmes ne sont
pas influencés par leur voisinage
ça faut demander aux fils je crois c'est
une sorte de voyage initiatique ça
commence dès la décision d'aller au
musée ensuite il ya tout le cérémonial
d'entrée c'est ce que j'appelle vous
savez les zones esthétique protéger et y
on le voyait pour le catalan parce qu'il
ya déjà la salle de musée tate est un
cadre puis ensuite il ya le cadre du
cube de protection et puis au fur et à
mesure on est mis en condition en
quelque sorte on a mis dans la condition
esthétique et puis au bout du compte il
ya ben je dirais que c'est normal qu'on
soit immédiatement absorbé par la
peinture et surtout qu'on limite parce
que je veux dire on a été mis en
condition pour s'imprégner de tout ça
moi je crois que c'est c'est un
phénomène parfaitement naturel le conte
le conditionnement des expériences
progrès
et là on voit bien ce garçon adoptent
quasiment
il ya un déhanchement est le début du
déhanchement payer surtout il a fait
attention de promettre un pull jaune
parce qu'il savait que j'allais être là
ce jour là qui étaient en accord avec
les cadres de francis bacon ya beaucoup
de photos chromatique en fait dans ses
montées avec des harmonies de ce que
nicolas je pense est sensible oui une
forme d'harmonie ou les patients en fait
je suis un photographe sérieux jeu avant
d'être photographe gt gt et je suis
encore peintre et dessinateur c'est
quand même mon activité première la
photographie c'est pour rire en fait
mais c'est un livre assez drôle
d'ailleurs et on voit bien mais est-ce
que vous avez attendu toute la journée
et non je dis je vous ai expliqué c'est
le désir absolu il faut que j'arrive
donc ça donc ça arrive j'ai énormément
de chance
d'être attentif il faut être très
attentif mais je il m'arrive quand même
très très très souvent d'aller au musée
sans faire de photos un coup je vais
voir une exposition je la regarde
d'abord avec mes yeux et puis je fais
une deuxième fois le parcours est hélas
je décide de faire des photographies on
voit aussi que là bas la belle à l'art a
eu de l'affluence sur la mode aussi
d'une certaine manière l inverse l
inverse
non mais il ya des ya des musées il ya
des musées très sérieux et très puissant
et très fort comme par exemple où c'est
un endroit absolument mais dément oui
vous n'est pas bien au louvre mais c'est
quand même un des plus beaux musées du
monde alors c'est vrai que déjà le plus
grand
l'ermitage et pas plus grand non non c
non c louvre non mais c'est un musée moi
je vais au louvre lorsque je me suis
blessé
interrompre on voit bien que c'est au
sexe féminin que vous faites allusion ah
bon mais
cette année j'ai fait ça ne va pas vous
mais
la coquille mais mais je comprends pas
que commencer disposé ce qu'elle fait là
c'était l'exposition de
dahmani au palazzo grassi et c'était
cette fameuse exposition incroyable
à la fois ridicule
exemple c'est une oeuvre de damien hirst
oui oui je pense je suis pas certain que
ce soit un vrai je pense que c'est
plutôt une sculpture mais ça peut être
un vrai don qu'elle était sur un sur un
plot comme ça c'est une ce qu'on appelle
une double valff valve nous a dit
philippe comar d'accord très bien
je comprends mais il ya aussi une
illustration dans ce livre de l'érotisme
du musée à la fois son côté bordel et
son côté salle de bains disait disait
michel leiris au musée un homme moi
malheureusement je suis marié avec une
fille extraordinaire donc et je suis
d'une fidélité redoutable n'y a pas de
tentation mais le musée certainement le
lieu de drague le plus formidable qui
soit
ah oui c'est pas je crois que c'était
les mariages je sais pas je ne me suis
mariée vient fois désolé les gens
flânent ils sont disponibles et ça soit
il se repose et repartent et une forme
d'un menu ma non c'est vrai que c'est un
endroit où on rencontre il y en a plus
tellement le jour ça c'est très beau
c'est très gracieux on dirait presque
des petites ballerines décidé par deux
là c'est à naples c'est à naples mais
vous voyez ça c'est incroyable parce que
moi je demanderais n'y a je ne demande
jamais rien aux gens de haut niveau
photographique gens font des trucs
formidables comme louis et toujours avec
beaucoup de grâce alors peut-être parce
que vous avez enlevé toutes celles où il
n'y avait pas de grâce mais voilà il ya
beaucoup de gens qui s'embrassent aussi
ébène jours je fais souvent un énorme
sexe oui oui toujours
sont toujours c'est l'art à l'état
gazeux pouvaient s'articuler les musées
mais oui je pense que de toute manière
on nous demande d'être en état de
réceptivité et donc les défenses sont
relâchés moi je crois que c'est aussi
une des raisons pour lesquelles aussi
aussi bien les défenses contre le
surprenant l'affreux aussi jeudi quand
on regarde toutes ces scènes de martyr
je veux dire c'est épouvantable il faut
neutraliser une grande partie de nos
réflexes naturels et bien il ya des
riads la laideur aussi dans les délais
il faut pas il ya de la les mêmes
riverains au louvre mais mais mais mais
il faudra accepter la laideur il faut il
faut déjà laissé tomber un certain
nombre de défenses 1 celle qui nous dit
que tout vrai de hbos par exemple il
faut aussi alors c'est très curieux
parce qu'il faut à la fois laissé tomber
c'était peut-être défense et en même
temps on reconstruire parce que par
exemple dans le musée la valorisation
sexuelle de des pièces n'est pas admise
1 c'est ce qu'on voit un petit peu dans
l'est dans les dents les photos de
l'origine du monde de gilbert et donc il
faut à la fois il veut dire neutraliser
le rejet de la pudeur mais en même temps
neutralisées
je le dirai mais l'attrait sexuel on
n'est pas fondée par essence et je
prends toujours l'exemple de du cored
jupiter enlevant you qui est une
peinture d'une sensualité incroyable et
les historiens de la voix veulent
jamais d'avoir dire ou pas c'est énorme
pas lui qui prend là l'équipe rend le
corps nu de you non non non non c'est du
maniérisme
fait c'est vrai mais vous c'est pareil
non
puisque comme vous êtes marié à une
femme extraordinaire
pas sensible à la sexualité des oeuvres
six mois si justement c'est là où je dis
il faut quand même reconnaître que l'art
est aussi fait pour satisfaire des
pulsions sexuelles très bien sûr là il
ya une vraie communication je trouve
entre ces trois femmes et j'inclus la
statue
et en plus cela la jeune fille tout
jeunes filles 1 me regarde et bon
d'accord je suis un type irrésistible
mais pas à ce point là quand même et
quel volume jamais ce qu'elle regarde
les stats alors là je vous assure qu
elle me regarda involontaire il regarde
le photographe au caylar garde le
photographe elle essaye de le séduire
dans cette pause l'est alambiquées et
est-ce que vous avez contacté tous ces
gens qui est ce que c est ce qu'ils
savent qu'ils sont dans le livre
aujourd'hui est ce qu'elle est le sait
bah vous allez créer des problèmes
mon avis vous en avez déjà si elle est
tentant de regarder l'émission
non mais je crois que les au niveau de
la legislation je crains rien je crois
bien je suis dans un lieu public
elle me regarde de face elle n'est pas
surprise il n'y a aucune légende de
désobligeantes c'est surtout les
légendes qui est importante méfiez vous
pour votre buren
[Rires]
ya un grain de diana et rien
n'est pas forcément bien vu il est pas
mort non non il va très bien alors la
formidable évidemment l'homme qui marche
ouais
vous auriez dû mettre l'autre celle avec
le
ecclestone
le avec le pictogramme sortie de route
de l'homme qui marche aussi mehal et ça
c'est épatant ca c ou c b lire non à
bâle une fois en face est un peu facile
la dame qui marche oui mais il se trouve
que il ya une harmonie stable en mai à
l'été un salam pied miracle ça marche
très très bien non mais elle aurait des
2,5 centimètres plus loin ou 5 cm plus
tôt ce serait moins bien
ça c'est formidable de me dire ça bah
oui vous avez inventé de la beauté qui
n'existaient pas merci voilà ce qu'est
la définition même de l'art là de même
s'acquitter le
cse c'est ce sculpteur anglais qui fait
des trucs épatant dans ces biens soient
et à ce qui est bien c'est gormley non
urbain gormley oui c'est vrai mais alors
ça c'est ridicule comme mc ça c'est
l'arc ça c'est l'art contemporain rien
oui moi j'adore parce que c'est le gazon
si vous voulez parce que regarder les
contorsions que ça demande un spectateur
aujourd'hui pour saisir quelque chose de
multimédia mais c'était pas où se mettre
il faut qu'il écoute kiseki regarde si
cet ordre c'est ça devient un gymnaste
le spectateur de multimédia
et alors là c'est pareil est-ce que je
tue d'oeuvres d'art ou c'est vraiment un
type qui buzz annoncé une oeuvre d'art
il y avait il y avait un chemin sans
spectateurs un spectateur on pouvait
passer par en dessous il avait des
dalles et cette salle absolument un
incroyable des jardins des palais du
jardini à à venise et on pouvait passer
par en dessous et le type on lui je les
ai attendus parce que oui bah oui
j'imagine mais un mot vous avez failli
envoyer votre femme non non
ce n'était pas de la salsa c'est les
gardiens alors ça c'est encore là tout
tout un univers esthétique qui s'est
ajoutée puisque avait pas de gardiens
autrefois pas s'il devait y en avoir non
c'est bien à chelsea
c'est intéressant mais ils ont toujours
des attitudes mort en parle c'est assez
récent non mais lui il est formidable et
je le connais bien depuis des années ça
fait déjà des années et c est
intéressant par exemple je me permets de
dire ça avec les textes de philippe
comme marcel questionnement il explique
tout des choses qui nous semblent
évidentes et qui ne le sont pas c'est à
dire un que les oeuvres soient gardées
ce n'était pas du tout cas par exemple
quand napoléon a fait revenir tous les
tableaux au louvre etc ou le fait qu'ils
aient des cartels des risques à la
retraite cartel il n'avait pas non plus
donc c'est tout le cartel je le rappelle
c'est la petite chose où il ya écrit
l'année l'auteur le titre et non et puis
il faut il faut il faut saluer les
gardiens je pense parce que
là l'autre jour j'étais à l'exposition
de cet allemand renversant vous savez je
l'aï dit je préfère ne pas prononcer son
nom et je suis allé voir les gardiens en
leur disant ça doit être terrible non de
rester là toute la journée et il était
formidable on a on a discuté et avec
beaucoup de sérieux ils mendient c'était
épouvantable monsieur et mais ces deux
parfois de bon critique d'art et souvent
ce sont des gens qui connaissent très
bien la peinture oui à force même si il
ya des gens qui sont peintres qui il ya
des fonds d'aidé ils préfèrent ils
préfèrent s'ennuyer notre milieu qui
leur plaît peut s'ennuyer à guichets de
la ratp en
finlande et l'autre avec mon sens dont
sauf quand c'est de l'art content pour
rien
l'épouvantable c'est effrayant être être
devant dès jeff koons ça doit être très
très dur quand même mais pardon vous
aimez jeff koons je ne me prononce pas
marseille je reste neutre toujours mais
je ne déteste pas ça je ne déteste pas
ça de même que j'aime bien ça mais c'est
de la déco quoi oui ça c'était c'était
la cafétaria à la biennale de la déco
voilà mais si ni les uns sequana a signé
sa ses cousins m'annoncer ça je sais pas
celle là est bien alors est ce que vous
avez fait exprès cécile guilbert où
c'est vraiment le hasard c'est le hasard
car il se trouve que ce jour là j'avais
un sac avait une sphère qui récuse
répondait parfaitement aux masques
d'andré breton et noir et blanc c'était
parfait
photos de man ray formidable ça
s'intitule voir et regarder l'art et ça
vient de paraître chez air cher on en a
vu qu'une partie est un livre formidable
ses meilleurs livres de photos que j'ai
vues depuis l'otan ont fait une pause on
se retrouve juste après avec yves
michaud qui va maintenant théorisé tout
ça
[Musique]
il me chaut vous êtes philosophe dans
l'art à l'état gazeux que vous aviez
fait paraître en 2003 vous décriviez une
double évolution
on est passés disiez vous des arts
traditionnels la peinture et la
sculpture à des installations qui
enveloppe les spectateurs ce serait ça
l'état gazeux et puis l'art s'est
répandue partout ça c'est
l'esthétisation de la vie et c'est là
dessus que ce que porte ce nouveau livre
intitulé l'art c'est fini et sous-titrés
et c'est sur l'hyper esthétique et les
atmosphères alors c'est quoi une paire
esthétisation massé l'esthétisation
disons alors de tout hyper et
allant du sommet à la base c'est à dire
en profondeur et
couvrant tous et c'est l'esthétisation
mais de tous généraliser la cuisine le
design les les odeurs
le meeting de mélenchon immersif
exercice et pas de l'esthétisation de la
politique je vais dire avec vaporisation
d'odeurs avec des musiques
laisser sa femme et ses utilisations
date pas de blanchot il y en a eu tout
au long du xxème siècle ben oui mais je
sois dans des dictatures
simplement ce que je dis c'est que
aujourd'hui les moyens de nous mener
directement au coeur de l'une des choses
que je dis c'est aujourd'hui les moyens
d'esthétique et non sont sans commune
mesure alors si vous faites allusion
effectivement hpr et hitler et je pense
d'ailleurs j'ai toujours regretté que je
perds n'est pas été condamnées à mort et
exécutées à nuremberg parce que il a
contribué au succès du nazisme d'une
manière exceptionnelle justement parler
s'est-il 1,06 pour les mérites fenstad
la leçon là la réalisatrice du triomphe
de la volonté non mais là non parce que
les par exemple si vous voulez
le succès de hitler est inconcevable
sans la sonorisation les lumières qui
est tout nouveau la sonorisation et les
lumières est ce que je dis c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
ces moyens 10 titres d'esthétique et
sont sans commune mesure avec ceux du
passé j'utilise souvent la la la la
comparaison avec l'air conditionné quand
on regarde l'histoire de l'air
conditionné qui commence à la fin du 19e
siècle les moyens aujourd'hui de
conditionner tout les atmosphères
sont sans commune mesure avec celle du
ps vous parlez de cette hyper
esthétisation de la beauté des
apparences aussi alors c'est vrai
paysage cdg vraiment les corps la
décoration
l'architecturé le design alors
architecture - justement parce que moi
je pense et si ces deux là dessus que je
prépare le prochain les way une
architecture a été notamment je dirais
complètement neutralisé produisent
attention quand elle a été réduite et
elle est devenue
artistique elle puisque c'est des
monuments veut dire même s'ils servent à
rien je veux dire mais ce qui m'a
frappée par de tout à l'heure avec les
photos de bacon le problème du centre
pompidou c'est que architecturalement
c'est ch et d'oeuvres des années 60 dans
le système
archi archi g de l'esthétique pop de l'
architecture mais en même temps c'est
tout à fait contraire je dirais à
l'exposition des oeuvres moi je me
souviens que mon ami tony gangs et des
sculpteurs disait il ya deux choses soit
impossible centre pompidou c'est le sol
avec ses petites lamelles de bois et
c'est la tuyauterie et des cas au dessus
je dirais on peut rien voir même s'il
n'ya pas de reflet si vous voulez on
peut vraiment pas voir mais en fait
c'est le centre pompidou qui est à voir
vous voyez c'est l'emballage et on en
arrive à ce que j'appelle les zones
esthétique protéger la l'art existe dans
ces zones esthétique protégé par exemple
est ce que vous pensez qu au 18e il y
avait un art des jardins très puissant
sûrement plus puissant que ce qu'il est
devenu aujourd'hui est ce qu on avait
conscience à ce moment là comme nous de
faire des zones artistiques provenant
des zones arctiques protéger non mais un
art ibères immersif et d'ambiance oui
oui le rococo la rocaille c'est ça
vraiment et c'est contre ça que c'est
pour ça que je suis pas et quand je dis
larimore cc c'est sûr mais je veux dire
je suis pas du tout pessimiste parce que
on peut très bien avoir un renversement
de séjour parce que justement à la fin
du xviiie siècle les gens sont vraiment
assez de ces dégoulinade de décoratif de
rococo et bien ça donne un le romantisme
d'un côté et 2 le néoclassicisme et
c'est complètement différent et c'est
lié à des changements politiques aussi
travaux dit que quand vous titrez votre
livre l'art c'est fini vous mettez entre
guillemets c'est vous reprenez une
expression populaire wii la wii c'est
l'art c'est fini l'art d'abord avec un
grand a et puis l'art je dirais comme
comme fétiche culturelle qu'on a eu dans
l'art moderne en quelque sorte notre
fétiche culturel majeur ça a été la
moderne dit je dirais depuis depuis
gauguin jusqu'à jusqu au postmodernisme
mais là ça je pense que ça s'est fini
s'est repris dans d'autres dans d'autres
atmosphère si vous voulez puisque les
gens vont dans les musées mais c'est
plus les mêmes fonctions que que l'ars
avait il y avait un art qui s'inscrivait
dans une histoire avec des avancées avec
des des conflits aussi y'a plus qu'à
plein conflit aujourd'hui dans l'art
contemporain tout le monde fait des
choses différentes et il n'y a plus il
ya plus de conflit et donc que je dirais
que cet art là maintenant il est passé à
un autre régime et c'est ce qu'on voit
très bien dans le livre de gilbert c'est
un régime finances alors ça et c'est pas
dans le livre de gilbert c'est un régime
financier c'est un régime de
divertissement alors ça c'est ce que
j'appelle hartenstein min le tourisme
parce que le tourisme c'est du
divertissement et il ya du bon
divertissement
et puis alors ça y est vous le gilbert
le photographier pas parce que c'était
ses plus récents mais la bondieuserie
aujourd'hui on a un arbre bondieuseries
est quelqu'un qui est sidérant c'est en
amont avec le politiquement et
moralement correct ah oui vous ai dit
écoutez gilles is est là et je lisais
ces jours ci le le la lettre de mission
de la nouvelle directrice de l'école des
beaux-arts comme j'ai été directeur de
l'école des beaux-arts cia 30 ans
intéresse quand même et je trouve que
c'est un très bon choix d'avoir nommé
alexis affable qui a fait un très beau
travail justement au mac val mais la
lettre de mission dit qu' elle doit
veiller à la diversité
des étudiants elle doit vite supprimer
le harcèlement elle doit mettre fin aux
elle doit décoloniser m ouvrira la
pluralité lgbt
cbc c'est un programme de volleyeuse riz
sulpicienne c'est pas un programme
progresser pas un programme d'art et si
je dis qu'aujourd'hui ça me sidère mais
aujourd'hui vous pouvez pas aller dans
une exposition d'art contemporain sont
tombés sur des bondieuseries je vais
dire moi je m 1 1 si je peux me
permettre je mettrais un tout petit
bémol à ce que vous dites parce que en
fait y est ma mise sur l'art content
pour rien moi je l'appelle directement
l'art contemporain rien une mainmise des
autorités de tutelle des ministères et
cdd très très grand collectionneur mais
à côté de ça il y à des artistes en
france
d'exceptionnel artistes dont je vais
parler d'un mort mais par exemple
sam szafran qui a fait une exposition
rétrospective de sam szafran qui est
certainement un des plus grands peintres
du xxème siècle qui perd sa personne
je suis quand je lis l'art l'art c'est
bien fini et c'est bien fini sous sa
forme sous sa forme sacralisé si vous
voulez mais jeudi il reste des artistes
de première importance a simplement le
problème aussi c'est que ces artistes
ils sont dans une sorte de vide et c'est
à dire que ce que j'appelle le
pluralisme indifférente east aujourd'hui
on peut tout faire depuis le
postmodernisme on peut tout faire j'ai
rien contre mais il ya plus de
références ce cri quand vous allez même
la politique des galeries moi-même
frappe beaucoup parce que avant et une
guide égard y avait une certaine ligne
aujourd'hui les galeries ils ont un
artiste africain et ils ont un artiste
lgbt ils ont un artiste de traditionnels
ils ont un artiste figuratif et y couvre
tout l'éventail si vous voulez mais ya
pas de ligne et je dirais que pour
l'artiste aussi c'est un problème c'est
de ne pas avoir de ligne parce qu'il
fait match etc est allée est ici là on
sait pas chez galets mais surtout lui
c'est pas non plus où aller je veux dire
parce que venir moi j'ai commencé ma
carrière
dans la rhd avec les gens de supports
surfaces quand on faisait de
l'abstraction c'était pour montrer que
l'oeuvre c'est le processus 1 mais
aujourd'hui quand les gens font de
l'abstraction décoratives ils se foutent
complètement il essaye de faire quelque
chose soit joli moi je suis très frappé
de voir qui a énormément de très belles
peintures décoratives abstraite
aujourd'hui mais pourquoi ils ont fait
ça quand on leur demande ils savent pas
d'une certaine manière non plus pourquoi
ils font ça et et je dirais que il reste
des artistes mais eux mêmes sont dans
une situation très difficile alors que
comme on commence raccrocher à quelque
chose y compris à d'autres artistes mais
est ce que c'est si dangereux d'essayer
de faire quelque chose de joli
nom part j'ai rien contenant leurs
décors et moi j'ai rien contre l'art
décoratif mais quand il est uniquement
décoratif ah oui ça devient du design il
veut dire à ce moment là on rende
redresser il est à la fois sur l'hyper
esthétisation mais aussi sur les
atmosphères alors qu'est ce que vous
appelez les atmosphères bas les
atmosphères c'est cette sorte de fusion
émotionnel et sentimentales ou le sujet
et l'objet ne se distingue plus en
quelque sorte quand on dit aujourd'hui
que le climat le climat des français le
climat des chefs d'entreprise est morose
c'est une atmosphère il ya des
atmosphères en politique il ya une
atmosphère morale aujourd'hui il faut
que ce soit tout le monde soit correcte
par un mot au dessus de l'aude pas
vulgaire paraît pas dire des choses est
néanmoins les gens cherchent des
punchline ce qu'ils appellent les
punchline mais attention sans trop
exagérer un sinon vous serez poursuivis
une atmosphère c'est je dirais que alors
ça c'est le côté difficile de mon livre
ce que j'ai quand même mis dix ans à
l'écrire et et à vouloir si vous voulez
le mettre sur des bases solides une la
notion atmosphère oblige à penser
différemment de la manière dont on
pensait en philosophie j'irai
naturellement quand on pensait rapport
sujet objet sujet objet c'est le
spectateur face à un tableau en quelque
sorte à une bonne distance avec un
certain savoir mais avec un tableau qui
lui est étranger la fusion l'atmosphère
c'est la fusion quoi en quelques
secondes c'est c'est être dans le
tableau vous parliez de l'atmosphère du
musée tout à l'heure c'est une des
formes d'atmosphère alors là je pense
que sa demande notre approche
de tous les phénomènes de la vie quoi si
vous laissez le touriste qui se prend
seule fille devant la joconde qui l'a
pas regarder au fond oui ce qui me
frappe veut selphy à vous dire les
raisons mais ce qui me frappe le plus
maintenant quand je vais dans les
expositions c'est que les gens
photographier les hommes ils les
regardent plus vous avez dû le voir
ainsi l'exposition repin fois que le
superbe exposition j'ai les gens ne
regardez pas il photographie mais c'est
vrai partout dans les concerts c'est
pareil vous avez une forêt de joie avec
des avec leur téléphone oui c'est fini
le concernant je dire de alors là ça à
voir je dirais un on veut on veut avoir
été dans l'atmosphère on veut et
imaginairement en garder une trace mais
je pense que jamais les gens vont voir
ce qu'ils les photos qu'ils ont prises
il ya le côté le suspendant le conseil à
ce que vous appelez l'expérience
inoubliable qui est très importante
inquiète à des botteurs on veut vivre
des expériences inoubliables
et au concert justement le concert qu'on
va voir est censé être une expérience
inoubliable donc il faut le film et pour
avoir la trace qu il gardera jeu et en
même temps je dirais ceci on réfléchit
deux minutes on voit que les expériences
inoubliables
le performeur la répète tous les jours
je dirais que j'ai dit vous êtes là vous
vous dites c'est exceptionnel ce concert
dudamel mais demain il sera à vienne
pour faire exactement une expérience
aussi inoubliable il ya aussi je dirais
dans cette hyper esthétisation du monde
une industrialisation
le fait que de la consommation effective
et de la production le fait que
l'interprète ou performeur leur fais
tous les jours n'empêche pas que pour
chez le spectateur ce soit une
expérience bien sûr bien sûr pour lui
c'est inoubliable mais en première fois
que je suis allé à new york j'ai trouvé
c'était d'expériences inoubliables jeu
même si new york est comme ça même quand
oui bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr et ça
c'est votre cv votre expérience et voilà
c'est bon vous quel est vôtre ça
quelles sont les conséquences de l'ip
est respectée esthétisation s'est fait
que l'art soit partout le fait que ce
soit comme c'est aujourd'hui c'est pas
l'arc est partout c'est l'esthétique les
critiques pardon du coup je dirais ça
dévalorise considérablement l'art sauf à
lui donner d'autres valeurs quand je dis
que c'est l'argent la clarté le
divertissement et la bondieuserie c'est
les autres valeurs dollar celle qu'il
sauve en quelque sorte par rapport aux
valeurs esthétiques fortes du passé et
puis je dirais alors là ça ça nous mène
à des réflexions que j'ai esquissé
sur la personnalité de notre temps un
personnalité de notre temps qui est une
personnalité hédoniste qui veut sentir
qui veut s'immerger
qui veut du plaisir tout tout de suite
les données des deux mots c'est tout de
suite et encore les deux mots d'un
personnalités contemporaines tout de
suite avoir tout tout de suite et puis
encore comme comme l'enfant il ya du
plaisir il dira encore encore encore
dire et bah du coup ça explique beaucoup
de choses dans notre société je veux
dire il comprit y compris parents
d'aujourd'hui on part on commence à
parler de crise de la démocratie ce qui
me semble tout à fait juste parce
qu'effectivement la conception
traditionnelle de la démocratie la
conception forte c'est l'idée d'un
citoyen qui a un peu réfléchi censé être
un peu réfléchi et à vous voir des
programmes et avoir des idées et avoir
peut-être une idée non pas sur le grand
les lendemains qui chantent mais sur un
peu demain quoi en quelque sorte pas
aujourd'hui je dire si c'est encore est
tout de suite passé peut-être pas la
politique qui la porte c'est peut-être
le monde virtuel c'est peut-être dû le
désamour zuckerberg d'où le désamour de
la politique et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
ce primat des atmosphères a certainement
à voir aussi avec je dirais notre
désamour de la politique où notre ou
l'impuissance de la politique que je
veux dire c'est sous sa transformation
en atmosphère je vais encore une fois le
meeting de mélenchon mam a vraiment
beaucoup intéressé veut dire parce que
ça ressemble à une chose que vous
devriez serait difficile à photographier
mais c'est l'atelier des lumières à
paris
c'est bon ça ne c'est pas très sympa
pour mélenchon scrupules non mais ces
merdes labellisables sûr que si élevé
qu'il est aussi bon de l'atelier des
lumières est annexée mais qui en plus
est excellente et
l'atelier des lumières c'est un grand
espace rien à à bordeaux il y en a à
marseille et il y en a à paris vers la
rue saint-maurice un bond dans le 11e
cet immense espace qu'est telus friche
industrielle qui a été transformé en
lieu justement d' expérience immersive
dollar klimt il va y avoir du goût dali
que je vais aller voir parce qu'une
lente comment ils vont se débrouiller
vos gains et vous vous baignez dans des
projections à 360 degrés
ici à l'action des nations non mais même
y en a au plafond si c'est même pas 360°
sur une sphère avec une musique vous
pouvez déambuler alors là vous pouvez
les enfants sont couchés par terre les
parents aussi vous pouvez vous regardez
dans n'importe quelle position qu'elles
consentent je vous êtes immergés la dent
vous êtes dans votre klimt vous êtes
dans gauguin vous êtes vous êtes vous le
regardez plus et je me suis posé la
question sa marque quelle différence y
avait avec l'expérience de de klimt au
musée parce qu'aujourd'hui l'expérience
de klimt au musée quand il ya une grande
exposition elle est assez proche de
celle de l'atelier des lumières sans la
musique et sans sans compromis semble qu
on les accroche au plafond en quelque
sorte et l'atelier des lumières c'est
vraiment les atmosphères l'immersion à
l'état pur et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que vous avez un monde fou qui va
à l'atelier des lumières qui vient de
banlieue
massivement qu'il n'ira jamais au musée
et quelques différences entre les images
et la peinture c'est à dire qu'en fait
l'atelier des lumières son succès repose
sur l'immersion dans des images en
désignant pas de la peinture est
justement la question je voudrais vous
poser c'est quelle différence vous
faites entre l'hyper esthétique et les
spectacles de la spectacularisation
intégrale de la réalité parce que en
fait quand vous parlez d une politique
c'est la mise en spectacle de tous et
moi ce qui me frappe par exemple dans
l'art contemporain
alors c'est le cas à l'atelier des
lumières mais c'est le cas dans toutes
les grandes biennale et toutes les
foires d'art etc c'est la démesure des
formats c'est à dire qu'en fait on est
l'art contemporain repose beaucoup sur
la démesure des formats c'est à dire
quelque chose qui excède l'ère de la
sensibilité humaine d'une certaine façon
de nos perceptions ces drames on s'en
prend plein la tête où on s'en prend
plein de sensations si vous voulez
qu'ils sont qui masque chiche et rien
faute d'accord si vous regardez un
tirage vintage d'un grand photographe
dans des expos ancien si vous voulez
vous un effort de torsion et ou si vous
avez une démesure déformable vous prenez
le truc à la limite c'est même plus la
peine d'aller à l'export il suffit de
voir un beau gala côté parc d'attraction
très bien on est on
l'esthétique c'est le parc d'attractions
par la société du spectacle la démesure
de de quelque chose qui vient foudroyé
la sensibilité oui
mais bon je suis entièrement d'accord
avec vous et mais je vous rappellerai
que c'était la taille c'est des effets
de sublimes avec la définition du
sublime de grandes ce moment c'est grand
c'est grand c'est big ben la business
simplement quand vous dites grand format
non attention parce que des grands
formats du tintoret ou de rubens c'est
une plus transportable donc aujourd'hui
c'est là aussi on est dans une logique
esthétique qui est une logique de
logistique c'est à dire dans la plupart
des biennales aujourd'hui il ya cet
utilisateur très drôle d'un but par des
biennales les pièces sont faites sur
place mon verre ce déshonneur à
l'artiste et après elles seront
détruites très souvent sont détruites je
me souviens des expositions de michael
est au musée de lyon et de mccarthy au
musée d'art moderne d'art contemporain
de lyon je veux dire c'est est immense
et c'était tout à mettre à la décharge à
la fin c'est déjà ça non mais ce soir
c'est plus et c'est un art de
consommation et là on est dans
l'émission une question comme un défi
l'émission
par exemple si on regarde et je vais je
regarde sur l'écran de contrôle cette
emmission je trouve très belle le décor
tout est beau c'est magnifique la télé
normalement c'est laid les émissions
sont d'une laideur terrible et
décoration la façon de filmer tout est
horrible à la télé et c'est fait exprès
moi j'ai choisi que ce soit beau en quoi
ce serait un problème cette
esthétisation l'esthétisation n'applique
pas de la beauté on est d'accord
l'esthétisation ça peut être une
esthétisation gore à regarde aujourd'hui
mais je suis frappé de voir que beaucoup
de films sont de très bonne qualité son
corps et une esthétisation du il n'y a
pas de beauté c'est l'esthétisation dit
anne dans titane n'y a pas de beauté
mais est en même temps c'est beau et
c'est esthétique et vous êtes dans un
âge un univers parfaitement esthétique
d'accord pour pour revenir deux secondes
sur l'atelier des lumières moi je suis
pas un femme de van gogh c'est un très
très très grand peintre 1 je suis pas
très amoureux de van gogh la différence
entre l'atelier des lumières et de voir
un vrai van gogh c'est que quand on voit
un vrai van gogh on voit la patte du
peintre et quand on s'approche où on
comprend un mystère qu'il ya dans la
peinture jamais une projection à très
grande échelle et je suis une fleur mais
ce genre de choses mais je suis bien
c'est une illusion
il ya dans la projection vous pouvez
voir oui ou l'ariana également des
détails qu'on demande des détails que
vous ne voyez pas que prévu mais ses
détails qu'on ne verrait pas il n'était
pas destiné à être vu juste ici en
rapprochant jeu mais le problème c'est
qu'on ne peut plus se rapprocher des
tableaux les tableaux étaient
aujourd'hui un peu plus au laroche et
nourrit les terres navire affiche un ou
deux tableaux dont on peut pas se
rapprocher on peut parfaitement se
rapprocher d'une toute la falaise à quoi
est ce que ça tient le triomphe de
l'hyper esthétique yves michaud moi je
pense fondamentalement à nos capacités
techniques on a des capacités techniques
et technologiques j'ai beaucoup suivi ça
si vous voulez à partir du xviiie siècle
on est dans un monde où nos capacités
techniques et maintenant technologique
si vous voulez numériques rendent à peu
près tout faisable et tout contrôlable
donc on a beau nous confiner par exemple
parce qu'on avait le moyen technologique
de nous confiner on est exactement mais
exactement je les réussis celui-ci on
nous aurait on l'aurait fait mais comme
comme autant de la peste on nous aura
enfermés dans des lasers ont fermé la
ville vous lire les gens y parlera le
reste dit faux je veux dire les lions
les gros films ont autrefois ont fermé
la ville ont fermé pas les gens dans
leur appartement exactement mais du coup
ils ont la possibilité avec avec tout ce
qui est numérique moi je pense que le
metaverse de zuckerberg bientôt ça sera
le prolongement de l'hyper esthétique
alors simplement ce comme je le dis
quand même aussi à la fin c'est que dieu
merci où hélas par ce moment on retombe
dans le réel et à ce moment là ça fait
très mal mais en même temps on vous le
dit il ya un ultra conformisme
ballesteros faire rendre conforme bien
sûr tout le monde est à l'unisson parce
qu'on est on à la fois le besoin de se
singulariser à notre époque et on en a
les moyens le numérique par exemple nous
permet de singularisation mais en fait
on est toujours aussi à baigorri
exactement tout le monde tout le monde
est pareil mais chacun est différemment
et on le voit bien d'ailleurs et dans
ses projections les jeunes chez les
jeunes c'est très très drôle mais aussi
on le voit dans les photos de nicolas
guilbert et cet art contemporain qui se
veut transgressif au fond à fabriquer un
conformisme payer les gens obéissent un
certain nombre de règles je parle pas
seulement des artistes parlent des
amateurs des admirateurs du des gens qui
entourent ce milieu ah bon on aiderait
confort mais on est dans des phénomènes
de foule moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
faut relire le bon puisque la régie des
foules mais exactement et curieusement
je le dis un peu dans mon livre à la fin
du 19e siècle 19e chèque à deux phases
une phase rationaliste d'ingénierie
progrès indéfini et puis une phase aussi
spiritistes
fort bien parler et à la fin du 19e
siècle on a une montée justement de
toute la psychologie des émotions des
fusions des foules et serra qui va mener
la guerre de 14 je vais dire une fois il
faut voir en c c c c et je pense qu'on
est un petit peu dans ce monde dans un
monde là mais avec en plus des moyens
beaucoup plus puissants qu'on avait un
dixième succès le début du tourisme
culturel
c'est quoi le l'équivalent du dandysme
aujourd'hui parce que le dandysme c'est
le sait le 19e fort moment de
conformisme et en même temps des stés
d'hyper esthétisation jade hyper
esthétisation
je dirais peut-être que le post punk
pour elle pourrait être sa
hauteur
le bayer ou vous le donne en effet
je ne vois pas beaucoup et
[Rires]
peut-être que le grunge et dans les
années 90 était nourri
marché du rock des années 60 aucun
l'esthétique
les chemises de bûcherons
à 10 10 le dandy
et vol on en revient au rond-point de
début c'est quand en fait on n'arrête
pas de recycler je veux dire beaucoup de
choses que je dis dans mon livre elle
était déjà chez baudrillard elle était
déjà dans dans l'est dans les réflexions
sur la sur le pop art des années 50 60
je veux dire on refait régulièrement en
mai du coup aussi ce qui est à voir dans
notre goût de l'hymne de l'immédiat
c'est la perte de la mémoire voyez vous
du plaisir je le dis je l'analyse non
non non notre goût du plaisir il ya
l'instantané le plaisir c'est instantané
le vrai plaisir
puis c'est inattendu et c'est non mais
non non parce qu'on le répète on a des
recettes pour le plaisir les drogues par
exemple a cédé très bonne le tourisme le
voyage organisé ces cd mais on veut de
l'immédiat donc du coup on n'a plus de
mémoire
l'immédiat dans l'immédiat du plaisir
c'est de surtout ne pas se souvenir et
ne pas penser à l'avenir donc du coup je
veux dire on répète on répète
sont sans aucune difficulté et sans le
savoir
nicolas guilbert c'est horrible
c'est assez horrible et en même temps je
dis que si vous avez aussi une vision
historique un peu informés comme c'est
mon cas je veux dire il ya une chose qui
est sûre on a vécu sur l'idée que
l'histoire elle avait un sens qu'elle
était organisée qu'elle allait quelque
part un mois je crois plutôt que c'est
une commune comme la phrase de
shakespeare c'est une histoire racontée
par un idiot plein de bruit et de fureur
qui signifie rien et donc du coup il ya
toujours des surprises encore une fois
je veux dire le xviiie siècle débouche
sur quand même l'austérité du
néoclassicisme et révolte de la
révolution
donc c'est quand même quelque chose
c'est pas mal la révolution non mais non
mais
je me dis mais presque jamais de
jugement de valeur et ben oui mais c'est
ça moi je trouve que décrire ce que vous
dites sur la technique en fait c'est ça
mon avis la rupture parce que à partir
du moment où toute l'humanité prison est
prise en main par en fait d'aider des
arraisonnements technique
c'est là où on risque pas d'avoir une
sorte de détecter le souhaitent
y faisons à un moment je dis au fond
aujourd'hui on parle de capitalisme
esthétique moi je veux bien qu'on parle
de capitalisme esthétique mais c'est
nous qui voulons le capitalisme
esthétique si nous qui voulons acheter
des marques c'est nous qui voulons avoir
des
ddd des produits de luxe c'est nous qui
voulons du capitalisme esthétique et
dire c'est pas
dans mes ya des gens qui résiste quand
même non eh bien on peut toujours
essayer de résister mais je pense que le
courant n'est pas en faveur des
résistances petit
de tout temps de toute façon les gens
qui résistent et s'est de tout temps
on allait dire été meilleurs mais on
creuse on était très très peu nombreux
si la diarrhée encore des gens pour
continuer sur la il ya encore des gens
qui savent dessiner qui savent plaindre
parce que le grand truc ça a été de
faire croire à tout le monde que tout le
monde pouvait devenir un art bien sûr
c'est
un grand truc
chance
alors là je suis oui mais c'est lâchant
du chant se battait contre une époque
oui qu'ils étaient juste là à côté bien
sûr que chez d'une violence absolue mon
violence ne peut être pas mais j'y
allais réseau saison c'était violent
c'était c'était assez dur à leus et les
bons bien mais je ne sais pas c'est pas
si mal un par mois par rapport à
l'atelier des lumières à dire il ya une
perf acté avec ses pénates
c'est les pompiers d'aujourd'hui et ceux
ci ont d'ailleurs le mot de la fin
merci tous les trois d'avoir participé à
cette émission l'art est finie c'est
chez gallimard le livre de yves michaud
et voir et regarder l'art de de nicolas
hilbert ces chercheurs merci de nous
avoir suivi et on se retrouve au
prochain numéro
[Musique]